vous savez quand un jambon l'appel
jambon blanc c'est parce que je laime
blanc et quand on veut faire croire
qu'un jambon blanc il faut qu'ils soient
roses et bien c'est pas mon truc à moi
en fait pour remettre que le jambon rose
on a utilisé un produit qu'on appelle le
sel nitrites et est donc ce sel nitrites
et ça a permis de garder cette couleur
rose ça a permis aussi d'autres choses
ça a permis notamment d'avoir des fois
d'avion de moins bonne qualité
le risque du celles décrites et dans la
charcuterie
c'est le cancer colorectal on a l'eau
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qui a déclaré le sel nitrites et comme
un poison avéré pas probable avérée axel
kahn et hoult chercheurs sont venus au
parlement nous dire il ya un risque de
cancer il ya un risque avéré a laissé
nitrites et malheureusement on les
trouve dans beaucoup beaucoup de
produits on les trouve évidemment dans
le jambon blanc dans dans la rillette
pour certains dans le foie gras dans des
plats préparés dans des saucissons c'est
une saloperie de nitrites et vous savez
avant il y avait même avant qu'on
appelle du sel nitrites et on mettait du
nitrite et puis avec les charcutiers qui
avaient un peu la main lourde et donc
les gens y mourrait met immédiatement en
fait c'est l'effet cocktail des scènes
écrites et qu'ils rencontrent dans la
charcuterie le sens de la viande est en
fait dans le sens le faire et l'effet
cocktail entre celles nitrites et et le
faire qui a dans le sang ce cocktail là
et mortifère la régulation c'est
l'interdiction la régulation c'est de
dire ce produit là est dangereux le sel
nitrites et tu es donc on vous protège
on l'interdît
on va vous laisser à tous le temps de
vous adapter mais on va l'interdire
c'est aussi la france qui est
l'aiguillon européen pour arrêter de
dire c'est la faute de l'europe c'est
parce que nous aurons fait en france et
que nous porterons ce qu'il y a de
meilleur sur la table france que nous
irons le porter sur la table europe
bien sûr quand on parle de comorbidité
on parle de choses qui peuvent tuer les
français indirectement et sur le temps
ce qu'il faut c'est reprendre une
alimentation saine parce qu'on sait que
plus on met les poudres de perlimpinpin
plus le risque pour la santé est élevé